31 people have been killed in a methane
gas explosion and a disused gold mine in
South Africa the incident happened more
than a month ago in the city of welcome
but details are just coming out now the
miners were reportedly working illegally
and are from neighboring Lesotho Our
Father Miller is joining us now from
welcome in South Africa just bring us up
to date with what we know
well we've heard from the minister of
male resources here in South Africa or
who is part of the operation to try and
retrieve those bodies he his Department
along with the owners of the mine
Harmony gold and until now very little
has happened we've heard from Harmony
gold that they've been in discussions
because the difficulty they say is that
there's the presence of methane gas in
that shaft it was a disuse shaft one
that Harmony gold says was never
operational and I'm going to step out of
shock just to give you a better idea of
what we're looking at now at the moment
there is a security team surrounding
that mound of stones that you might see
and every so often you see that methane
gas and heat rising from what is
essentially a hole in the ground and
that's where these illegal miners
accessed the the mine shaft to mine gold
there's still gold in many of these mine
shafts in this area but they've been
closed down or abandoned because they
aren't financially viable for industrial
Mining and this is where illegal miners
come in so there are at least 31 bodies
down there as you say this explosion
took place a month ago and it's just
after that that family members of these
miners approached authorities in Lesotho
neighboring Lesotho a country that's
surrounded by South Africa and it's
thought that even illegal miners who are
in this area didn't approach police here
because of their activities and that
they're illegal and they feared being
arrested so family members of these
illegal miners approach authorities in
Lesotho and that's when authorities in
South Africa were contacted and this is
why it's only coming to light now so
it's a very slow start to this operation
because of the presence of methane gas
there's a concern they may be further
explosions and their logistical and
safety challenges for both the
government and Harmony gold in trying to
retrieve those bodies you've been
reporting on illegal mining as an
ongoing issue for South Africa for a
long time for Al jazeer family imagine
because it's illegal though limits the
amount of legal recourse there might be
for the families of the victims just how
bad is the situation with illegal mining
in South Africa
well it's a very complex situation for
the South African government and also
owners of these mines they're at least 6
000 abandoned mines in South Africa and
very difficult to monitor it would
involve a lot of security and also
implementation of policies to try ensure
that this doesn't continue There are
tens of thousands of illegal miners some
of them calling themselves artisanal
Miners and they're pushing for the
government to regulate the trade so that
incidents like this don't happen so that
there is greater safety and that perhaps
that they can feed into the economy and
so that this trade isn't illicit at the
moment we know that many of these miners
spent weeks even months underground in
in cramped shafts in the dark where it's
very very hot and where there's very
poor infrastructure and certainly safety
is a concern once the sand that contains
either gold that contains gold is
brought up it's taken to the inform low
processing plants in informal
settlements for example and then this is
fit into an international market the
South African government says it loses
millions of dollars every year so it's a
situation that's difficult for them to
manage and one where we continue to see
disasters like this one family thank you
very much that's farmer de Miller
talking to us from welcome in South
Africa